non allez je m'indigne on venait avec
moi toi normale et mathieu alors c'est
très simple première épreuve la première
épreuve
elle est là je vous le dis 2 il ya kho
lanta qui reprend guerrière ces coupes
elle il y a un gros ver blanc à manger
et soul autres coupes l'ol il y à un
délicieux verre c'est un bonbon voilà un
verre voilà un bonbon à la fraise
alors allez-y honneur à norman il
choisit je kiffe ce jeu c'est vraiment
super ouais t'as carrière commence il
est vivant le vert je sais pas moi c'est
pas moi qui fais les coupelles joue les
voilà bah vous allez au dégivrage et le
banc contre cellectis et la demande mais
voilà et manger plein c'est pas possible
inquiétez pas ça mais c'est rien et vous
allez voir quand vous avez croqué il va
lâcher comme un petit truc impossible ça
vous pouvez donc possible mais c'est
rien il est très vite très vite
derrière une des boîtes il y à un
serpent oh non non non faut arrêter là
je reprends les agresseurs belanov je
veux je peux vraiment des fire non mais
vous inquiétez pas venez de mon côté
dans une des boîtes il ya un serpent non
non et dans l'autre il y à un bois un
serpent en plastique d'accord non et je
n'y mets alors ça vous choisissez c'est
bon non mais juste vous touchez un peu
de cire pourquoi la série a les abonnés
quelle boîte à tata après qu'elle l'ait
dit salah el al et vic alboini je
l'espérais quel bois elle inquiète lé
match - celle-là plus à la mode et la
[ __ ] et venez là mais ici mais je sais
et
c'est le vrai ou pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc normal enfin on comprend tout
normalement balle vraiment phobie total
je sais que c'est un peuple attendait
regarde c'est peut-être pas sur un qu'il
y soit allé y regarder il est là il est
vraiment dégueulasse je n'ai rien à ça
regardez c'est du serpent d'eau douce ce
magnifique fait du sar sur la tête sur
la tête
bon allez c'est là il ya il y a deux
personnes ici vous pouvez le noir il ya
deux personnes il y en a ils ces deux
personnes
baru ces deux personnes il y en a un qui
est champion de karaté et l'autre il n'a
jamais fait de karaté de sa vie d'accord
cela s'appelle brian et l'autre
s'appelle thibault s'appelle brian love
you soon d'ours
vous devez appeler au hasard brian ou
thibault il devra vous mettre un coup de
pied de karaté c'est quoi bryan bryan
[ __ ]
alors brian juste petite question est-ce
que vous avez déjà p je vous avais déjà
fait du karaté
oui j'ai déjà fait auparavant quand
j'étais petit et vous jamais jamais
c'est thomas daigneault alors tous à
quelque chose quand même
oui merci anne elle coûte 100 m dans les
roms ouais voilà voilà mathieu vous
allez vous mettre la sève vous avez eu à
la fin à 14h [ __ ] mettez-vous là je
vais tomber sur sept gars quand même
voilà il va tu sors tu fais un boulot un
web j'adore tout en continuant jeu ce
qui attend un dernier un dernier rôle
[ __ ] mais bon dieu merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez eu un centre d entre elles il
a il a toujours des chances